I have no idea what to say about this
Lakers team but I know somebody who can
help me figure this thing out is the
undefeated
Marc Spears joining the Rich Eisen show
and look Marc I'm still trying to figure
it out
I'm asking people I'm trying to find my
insiders I lean on you because this
wasn't what we expected before the
season started 19 games left and I still
can't figure out the Lakers well maybe
our expectations were too high mm-hmm
like if you go look at Vegas in the eyes
and I don't know if you remember this
he had this tat we're tied I think with
Boston for the second best odds to win
the title not just building the
championship I mean I wouldn't make the
playoffs around the title behind the
Warriors so perhaps Vegas was fooling
everybody a little bit to get some bets
in but you know this team has one
all-star one superstore and had a lot of
young guys that had a lot of growing up
to do so you know I I always kind of
felt like it was a challenge to make it
to the playoffs but when you have LeBron
James in the roster I think everybody
just assumed that anything was possible
but when you look at the Western
Conference and LeBron coming over to the
Western Conference look you understand
that there is going to be some tough
games with OKC the Warriors Denver
Nuggets Portland but when you lose to
the Phoenix Suns the worst team in the
NBA mark that's inexcusable to me that
tells me there's something going on
inside of that locker room whether it's
the coaching staff to the players guys
not believing and you read those
comments after the players don't know
how to figure it out so what's their
next to do yeah I mean it's not just the
Suns they've lost to a lot of bad teams
right and if they just win those games
against the bad teams they're in playoff
position I mean we could blame you
maybe Lonzo is more important than we
thought the New Orleans hangover you
know there's a lot of things but
ultimately there's also a chemistry deal
as well I remember when I covered the
Celtics in 2007 eighth year they won a
title there was a lot of new people
involved Kevin Garnett arrived
Ray Allen arrived and if you talk to Ray
and Paul and kg what really helped them
was going to London going to Italy in in
getting camaraderie and building a
teamwork and learning about
unselfishness you know away from America
like being forced to be together and I
thought that you know I talked to Rondo
about that early in the season he said
he wished that this team had that kind
of opportunity to grow together and get
to know each other better because
obviously the chemistry is horrible
there's a lot of fingers to be pointed
which I think that's where a lot of the
frustration is like what is the real
reason but um you know ultimately when
you have a LeBron James on your team you
know the finger probably is gonna have
to be pointed at him because some people
you know view him as the best player to
ever play in the world ever he's been to
eight straight finals and he I think he
hadn't missed the playoffs since 2004 so
just with him alone the expectation is
that the rest of the guys would pick up
their game and grow with him being there
but such hasn't been the case
senior NBA writer for the undefeated
Marc Spears joining the Rich Eisen show
Kirk Morrison filling in for Rich but I
think mark what happens is to is so many
things that LeBron James is involved in
before he got to Los Angeles and now
since he's been in Los Angeles all these
new opportunities keep popping up and
his hand seemed to be in everything and
in reading your piece from the other day
on the undefeated about Kobe Bryant Kobe
was all in on basketball and he waited
till he retired to get into movies and
film and all the different endeavors now
that he's a part of when you look at
LeBron James and what he's doing and now
you see that his basketball team seems
to be suffering does that also factor
into what a lot of people are kind of
maybe upset about or will use as a a
blame to put on the brunt I mean but so
I think that might be just an excuse
that people are using
but he's still bawling he was in
nineteen and four boards like that but
if there is somebody that could like put
all this stuff on his plate and still
perform it's him regardless of whether
he's filming Space Jam or there's
darkness or I don't know that that
really matters I think where anyway man
you you know LA and you know how big the
press conferences in that way Jim Hill
asking the first question LA I think
that in hindsight LeBron pride should
have you know done the LA tradition do
the press conference get the city to get
to know him more instead of not doing
anything until training camp and I also
think will be good for him to go to
South Central go to East LA maybe do a
lot of the a lot of the great things
that he does perhaps do that more in the
LA community so they could get to know
him a little better cuz I don't like he
he's a said some of the reporters there
well you guys don't really know me I
think it would be good for them to get
to know him more but he's become such a
big star
perhaps that's kind of gone by the
wayside but I don't I won't use his
moonlighting as an excuse because his
numbers are still really great but what
about the big star over in Boston a
former teammate of LeBron James and
Kyrie Irving talking about you know the
embracing of a City Boston seemed to
embrace Kyrie they'll he didn't play in
the playoffs Laurie it wasn't a part of
that that run all the way to
one game before the conference follow me
the NBA Finals that they lost to LeBron
James but yet before the season started
saying I want to be a Celtic if you have
me and now we look at where they're at
right now this point of season and I'm
not so it doesn't seem like he wants to
be there nor does the team seem like
they want to be on the same page what's
going on in Boston so you know they with
their struggles and with Kyrie speaking
out I'm sure some of those guys are
saying hey you know we won without him
last year we could do that yeah we could
do better without them so I'm sure
that's another play that is another
place where the chemistry issues are
there and you know I mentioned having
worked in Boston before and I really
wish Kyrie didn't make that promise
he didn't have to you know and that's
the city where you gonna make a promise
somewhere and they expect it to happen
that certainly gives one of those places
there's a lot of pride there there's a
lot of ego there there's a lot of titles
there so you know there was really no
reason for Kyrie to say I'm coming back
well you guys had me and then changing
his mind he kind of made it bad in a
fashion that could come back and bite
them and then you've heard to talk about
it maybe going to New York can you
imagine him going back to Boston or
Knicks uniform game would be I mean you
this is a franchise who threw rocks at
the Lakers bus after beating the Lakers
in the championship in 2008 it could be
it dare I say somewhat dangerous it's
great to them to come back to Boston you
know time will tell but seems more more
that the tide is leaning towards him
departing from a place and he polishing
a promise in the first place senior NBA
rider for the undefeated Marc Spears
joining the Rich Eisen show Curt
Morrison and for rich so how do they fix
it though Marc like what can because the
one thing about the difference between
the Lakers and the Celtics are that
Boston is actually right now in the
playoffs are the fifth seed in the East
that they'll be playing but
it's it's hard to see them making any
movement or scaring anybody wouldn't
seem like they're not collectively
together as a unit
I mean it's it's embarrassing that that
assists me they have the talent to be
number one they have the most talent in
the Eastern Conference gordon hayward
hasn't lived up to what he was before he
was injured
chemistry is bad as Jason Tatum really
taking a step forward I don't know I
mean kind of going back here
you're Lakers I think the pelicans
should have made that move but they
appear to be so upset at the Lakers that
there was no way that they're gonna make
that trade if they're waiting on tato I
don't know that I agree that Tatum alone
is better than getting Ingram Kuzma you
know ball and perhaps harden to first I
mean our the Lakers offered I think the
Lakers offered the pelicans or Herschel
Walker Trey Davis all right and it might
have been a benefit in the skies at that
trade didn't go down despite how bad
things look right now but now when you
talk about the play on the court now not
just the drama off of it though Marc
you're looking at Giannis antetokounmpo
as well when it comes down to the MVP
hardened already the reigning MVP kind
of who's der your frontrunner right now
is it gonna go to a team with the best
player on the best team in the NBA or
could a guy like Paul George sneak up to
get it could Kawhi Leonard get up is it
gonna go to a team I'm big on record
right and you know not not just stats
but record to and to me right now Yanis
is far and above the the MVP of the
league Bucks have I believed the best
record in the league right now and he's
playing amazing you know that's not to
say that
James Harden isn't playing well but you
know there's their records not the best
in the west and they're not even top
three
you know Paul George is probably a
better candidate then you know he's
getting credit for but I mean some more
wins by the Thunder maybe sneaking up
into that two spot would help us cause
right now but I'd unless the Bucks do a
downward downward spiral I am expected
Yanis to get the MVP award and he really
wants the truth senior NBA rider for the
undefeated Marc Spears a couple more
before I let you go mark the one thing
that over the last I guess couple days
or last couple weeks that I've seen when
watching the NBA is that obviously
there's big games and there's just game
that people kind of watch from night to
night but we've seen some absolutely I
don't want to call them horrendous but
bad caused by the officials we saw last
night that Trey young got ejected in the
third quarter for staring down a player
do they call taunting and then we've
seen players now tweet at NBA officials
how was that going over with the league
office that players are trying to figure
out why am I get I think the call on
Saturday night on Josh Hart against
DeAndre Aiden you say hey what did I do
wrong is that good for the league that
players can kind of question a call by
tweeting Adam or going at the officials
is that what Adam silver is is that
something they're okay with it's also I
think a message of there's a lot of new
referees now when you watch them how
many these guys you recognize not that
many I mean I don't know how close
you're going the teens right but you
know all the really really great
referees are gone right like now I Jax I
was like a veteran referee in this
league Joe to Joey Crawford the
Crawfords in the world and the Borgata
and you know all those guys are gone
they've not only lost some veteran
referees that were really really good
javi you know but if you
watch closely on some of the top
basketball games in college you'll see
former NBA rest there I think a lot of
the veteran retired cuz one they're
getting old and but I think a majority
of it is they're tired of all the
climbers being on them everything being
judged in slow motion just such there's
so much pressure being an NBA rough
there's a lot of thing with the very
thing without although they get paid
really well so I a lot of their old
heads are gone and a lot of these new
young guys are trying to establish
himself in the league and make the
presence known instead of just roughing
the games like the one with Trey young
yesterday was just ridiculous I mean
trash-talking is part of the game even
Reggie Miller tweeted about that it's
just um you know I was at a game in the
d-league showcase and there was a
referee who called a technical on a
player for taunting and it was a player
who was playing really really well on
NBA teams were like getting a chance to
see him down the showcase former NBA
player and his second tech kicked him
out of the game when he was in the
middle of a hot streak and you just felt
like the whole enthusiasm of the game
just went out the door man and everybody
kind of looking at the ref like why'd
you do that you know so another thing I
think of all these young rats need to do
is just take a step back and look at
that these people were here to watch the
players play and not some of the
referees right yeah I hear you're mark
but I'm still watching though but still
you know I want to see Trey young stay
in the game you know what I mean don't
do that to me refs hey Mark appreciate
the time man always good
that's mark spear senior NBA writer of
the undefeated the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience